what is up everybody its Anna Mike here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the most recent
developments in the black clovers story
including the definitive setup for a new
story arc that is going to be taking
place outside of the clover kingdom that
means that a lot more world-building is
coming our way which is awesome and
that's not all we also just had a new
member of the Black Bulls officially
confirmed in the manga and personally I
am extremely happy about this news so
let's talk about all of it right now if
you enjoyed the black clover content on
this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you can be notified
every time a new black clover video is
uploaded heads up this video will
contain spoilers from the black clover
manga we're dealing with all the latest
developments in the story so far so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned picking up where the
previous chapter left off
chapter 219 takes us back to the magic
congress building after the black falls
broke in to save sucre and hasta from
this blatantly unjust trial the black
bulls being the weirdo that they are
start getting into some friendly and not
so friendly banter with each other right
away and they do it in front of everyone
including of course damnatio and all the
obnoxious nobles Yami addresses damnatio
directly as a member of the royal Kira
house and Yami says that damnatio has
two of his black bull members in his
loving care and of course Yami you would
like them back Sakura fires back by
saying not to waste time on her instead
they should just take hasta and go
because she doesn't belong to the people
of this generation anyway and she
already accepts responsibility for using
forbidden magic in this chapter Sakura
really proves herself to be a selfless
and noble person noble in the true sense
of the word not in the sense of these
stuck-up obnoxious Nobles of the kingdom
Sakura accepts all the consequences of
her actions and she accepts the
punishment that will be handed out to
her for using forbidden magic even
though we all know that she only used
that in order to save the entire kingdom
sacré is clearly committed to duty and
honor and she would gladly sacrifice her
own freedom her own humanity and
probably her own life
for the greater good of the clover
kingdom that is something that we really
have to respect especially considering
everything Sakura had to go through for
the sake of the kingdom up to this point
however Yami isn't having any of that he
says that Sacre as the bird Nero had
already made herself comfortable in the
home of the black bulls the other black
bulls jump in and you can bet that mag
nine FINRA wants a crate to join the
squad
Magnus says that despite being a girl
Sakura's ability to be a bird for 500
years was hella manly and Finn role of
course says that cute girls are always
welcomed with the black bull no surprise
that FINRA would say this because we all
know that he's an absolute Chad Gordon
Vanessa and Charmy are also happy to
welcome Sacre as the newest member of
the black bull squad Yami says that the
black bulls are already a bunch of
weirdos and outcasts people who are
looked down on by the so-called high
society of the clover Kingdom so even if
Sacre has demon horns
even if she used forbidden magic even if
she was a bird for 500 years no one is
going to bat an eye if she joins the
black bulls because she's just going to
be another weirdo just like the rest of
them this is such a great moment in my
opinion because it emphasizes the true
nature of the black Bulls as a squad
this has been a reoccurring theme in the
series but it's clear that the black
bulls are a group that welcomes those
who have been cast aside by the rest of
society the black Bulls welcomed those
who are different those who were not
born with the privileges of nobility
those who would never have even been
considered by many of the other squads
in the first place as a foreigner who
faced discrimination because he is
different from everyone else Yami made
it a point to recruit people who also
faced discrimination and social
rejection for one reason or another and
the entire black bull squad is a band of
weirdos and misfits but that is
precisely what makes them so memorable
so badass and so awesome
I mentioned in my last Block lower video
that the black bulls are one of the
greatest squads in anime in my opinion
and the fact that they are all such
unique misfit characters is a huge part
of that
sakra things back to the first wizard
King Lumiere and how he told her to be
happy with all her friends from this
generation and then suddenly Sacre makes
her decision she uses her magic to break
through the handcuffs and suddenly we
see that she is wearing a black Bulls
robe
sacré aka Nero just became a new
official and confirmed member of the
legendary black Bulls magic Knight squad
this really was an epic moment for all
of us who are fans of the black Bulls
and I am really looking forward to
seeing this scene animated once the
anime catches up if handled well with
the right music and visuals this could
be one of the best and most heartwarming
scenes in the entire black clover anime
but we can't get too comfortable here
because damnatio still refuses to accept
the current situation he says that the
interruption that the black bulls just
created is just going to hurt Asta's
case even more and the fact is that none
of the members of the magic congress
have been convinced that hasta is no
longer a threat just because he now has
a few friends supporting him damnatio
then uses his scale magic to balance out
the powers of everyone in the room
making most of the black bulls weaker
damnatio gloats about how all powerful
magic is meaningless before him but that
gloating lasts a whole two seconds
before hasta uses his anti magic to
nullify damnatio scale magic Yami then
rushes them natio with his sword but
before he can give them natio what's
coming to him
foo golden Vermillion and nose el Silva
intervene they stop Yami from reaching
damnatio and they warn him against going
too far
no Zelan Fugo leone state that there are
citizens inside the clover kingdom who
recognized the capabilities of the black
bulls and the good work they have done
for the kingdom regardless of their
social class and they revealed that the
wizard king himself
julius noah chrono has ordered the
entire black bull squad to leave the
kingdom along with hasta the black bulls
were ordered to monitor hasta the kid
who has been linked to a demon while
they're all safely away in a foreign
land Yami quickly realizes what just
happened
Julius used the power of his own royal
privilege along with the reputation of
two
magic night captain's who happened to
also have royal blood to make his
mission for Austin the black bulls
legitimate in the eyes of the kingdom
including the nobles by effectively
exiling the black balls and hasta Julius
will keep them away from the nobles who
are calling for Oscars execution this
new mission will also buy us the time to
prove his innocence
finally in very importantly by doing
this Julius is attempting to avoid what
I warned about in my last blog clover
video and that is an all-out Civil War
Between the stuck-up nobles of the
clover Kingdom and pretty much everyone
else I mean just think about it if Fugo
Leon and know Zell didn't show up when
they did and Yami attacked and killed or
seriously injured damnatio a member of
the House Kira in front of the entire
magic Congress every member of the black
bull squad would have been labeled a
terrorist an attack on a member of house
Kira someone who is close to the king
himself would have meant that there is
no going back for the black bulls the
nobles would have called for all of
their heads and large scale conflict
would have been inevitable the few
nobles who don't discriminate against
others and who are not stuck up in
pompous elitists would not be able to
support the black bulls any longer if
the black bulls were labeled as
terrorists it would be too late for any
type of peaceful solution you would have
to be either with the black bulls or
with the nobles everyone would be forced
to choose sides and a massive conflict
would inevitably ensue some very
powerful individuals including King
Augustus Kira clover would demand the
heads of every black bull immediately
and anyone who wanted to help the black
bulls or protect them would also be
labeled a terrorist there would just be
no going back but by coming up with this
mission which will take Austin the black
bulls outside of the kingdom julius
avoided a potential civil war that would
have been a very deadly conflict for the
citizens of the clover kingdom with
hasta far away from the kingdom the
nobles can't complain that he poses a
real threat to them and by being outside
of the kingdom aster doesn't have to
worry about unfair inquisitions going
after him he now has the opportunity to
prove his innocence together with all
his black vol friends away from the
constant scrutiny of the nobles from a
narrative perspective this new mission
also advances the
what we are now going to get to explore
the world of black clover beyond the
clover kingdom and I'm very excited for
that my guess is that eventually the
black balls will make their way to the
Spade Kingdom the rapidly expanding
militaristic Kingdom that is also known
as the demon kingdom of Spain this means
that we are going to learn why exactly
Spade is referred to as the demon
kingdom and we will explore the
mysterious connection this kingdom has
with the demons I am very curious to
find out how the Spade kingdom is
connected to the demons and while I was
hoping that Yami and the black bulls
would finally give them the issue and
the obnoxious Nobles of what's coming to
them and I am kind of disappointed that
everything was ultimately resolved so
peacefully thanks to Julius we have to
remember that if this conflict really
escalated into a civil war it would not
have been good for anyone whenever there
is a war civil or otherwise the people
who suffer the most are the poorest and
least powerful members of society
the rich and powerful have the means to
get out of harm's way they have places
to go and they can use their money and
influence to protect themselves the
common everyday people who don't have
money or power are always the ones who
suffer the most because they are the
ones who always find themselves on the
front lines so in the end as much as I
wanted to see the nobles get their just
desserts this is the best decision for
everyone and this mission the Julius
came up with and how he went about it
proves that despite being a kid Julius
is still extremely intelligent and a
master strategist I am very much looking
forward to seeing where the story will
go from here
I love the magical world of black horror
and I'm happy that more world building
is coming our way let me know what you
guys think Are you disappointed that
Dame natio didn't get rekt by Yami or do
you think that this was for the best
also where exactly do you think that the
black balls will go after leaving the
clover Kingdom let me know down below if
you enjoyed the black clover content on
this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell you can also follow me
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest black clover news and
updates i want to give a big thank you
to all of our
anime opera patrons for supporting our
work and making our videos possible a
special thank you to all of our pro hero
to your patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson King zelgius and on hell crews on
Epic thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah al Olin Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and Keylong and finally at
the pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Regan
Harrison and Lord Noxon or disciples of
Lord we go himself if you enjoy our
videos and you think they provide value
for you consider supporting us on
patreon link in the description even a
single dollar will give you access to
our exclusive patron only discord and
your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]